we will solve this mystery tomorrow I'm
Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle from
Washington tonight the China apologist
that's the focus of tonight's angle
all right just in time for the
Thanksgiving holiday was supposed to
make us all feel kind of warm and fuzzy
inside Biden was working his magic once
again easing tensions President Biden
she cover a range of issues during a
three-hour meeting in Bali it did give
president XI an opportunity to uh to uh
talk more about his meeting with Biden
which did raise hopes that there was
going to be some sort of a thaw in U.S
China relations both leaders in their
opening remarks expressed the need to
find common ground to find things they
could work on and Common Ground now why
would the White House grovel for a
dialogue with G he's a man engaged in a
Non-Stop campaign of domestic Terror
against any dissenters
and why would Biden's team seek to
normalize relations with a brutal Tyrant
who hates everything and I mean
everything that we stand for
now the fact is China doesn't have to
invade the United States to subdue and
change us
it already has it has enormous influence
on our lives here through the powerful
people and institutions it's bought off
to the Strategic Acquisitions it's made
to the technology it's stolen to the
deadly drugs it's sent here
as long as it's run by the CCP China is
our enemy period
but not according to so many of our
Elites and politics and Academia
entertainment and business in fact many
in our billionaire class spend their
days making excuses for the CCP even
apologizing for the most you know muted
Western criticism like Michael Bloomberg
who famously claimed that she was not a
dictator at all and that XI listens to
his people
then last week Bloomberg apologized to
China when former UK prime minister
Boris Johnson called the CCP a coercive
autocracy those are pretty bland words
if you ask me
so how sick is it that Bloomberg who
actually sits on a U.S government
defense Advisory Board
is defending a dictatorship against the
true words of an ally
now I've said this before but we feel
terrible for the innocent people of
China we don't blame them
look at what they're enduring right now
bravely protesting the horrific coveted
lockdowns that are just being used to
manipulate the population of China
there was an explosion of rage and fury
this weekend
all right
[Applause]
how can we ever cooperate and compromise
with this type of country
now we shouldn't be looking for an armed
conflict with China I'm not saying that
but we also need to stop fooling
ourselves that like Russia is more
dangerous than Beijing in any way shape
or form it is not
and we need to be realistic about the
severe Peril that we'll face as long as
she is in charge
he doesn't distinguish between red and
blue states he has utter contempt for
all Americans and his ultimate goal is
world domination
of course China's apologists and
enablers they don't give a rip take
Apple for example now this is the same
company whose CEO was quick to embrace
the whole systemic racism narrative that
persisted in the summer of 2020. I want
to address the topic of racism
inequality and Injustice and to
recognize the pain being felt throughout
our nation especially in our black and
brown communities after the senseless
killing of George Floyd this country was
founded on the principles of freedom and
equality for all
for too many people and for too long we
haven't lived up to those ideals
we're inspired and moved by the
passionate people around our nation and
around the world who have stood up to
demand change
hmm why isn't Tim inspired and moved by
all the passionate people in China
tonight because they're actually putting
their lives at risk by standing up for
basic human rights
but rather than standing up to this
sadistic regime in China Apple's
collaborating with it by working with
China's secret police to clamp down on
dissent during the ongoing coveted
protests they're doing this by agreeing
to block the use of its file sharing
feature
like all the other big Tech CEOs cook
has no moral qualms about making
billions off the oppression of others
half of the world's iPhones are now made
in China
now Elon Musk he's no better sadly sad
to report that he has a big
manufacturing facility for Tesla there
but we're going to see how happy Elon is
when China begins exporting more of its
own EVS than Tesla does
now the fact is like so many lies told
about China by corrupt forces here we
now see that technology has not made
China Freer it simply made the
dictatorship there more efficient in its
crackdowns
but the judges on the Supreme Court of
globalism they're oblivious
we have to Define how the world should
look like which we want to come out of
this transformation period I
respect China's
achievements which are tremendous over
the last over 40 years I think it's a
role model for many countries
a whole model for many countries now we
know Klaus Schwab would sell out his own
mother for power and access to the
Chinese markets and our so-called allies
in Europe they're no better
the best NATO can do is call China a
challenge thanks Italy is closing up to
the CCP on trade now
Hungary is looking to G for cash
and after covering up the origins of its
virus that killed Millions across the
globe after indirectly funding Russia's
war in Ukraine China is going to be
rewarded with visits from the EU
president in a few days with French
president macron following soon after
clearly we stand alone against China on
the international stage
but I think we should at least have a
kind of a strong response to China
domestically right well this is how the
White House responded to the mass
protests in China
and the leader of the Free World is just
as bad Biden's NSC spokesperson said
that zero covid wasn't a policy we're
pursuing here
they could if they would and that it
would be very difficult for China to
keep the strategy going big deal
the Biden team though went from
criticism that was kind of muted
to something that was just plain
pathetic
what is the president's reaction when he
hears protesters in China chant Freedom
or Xi Jinping step down the president is
not going to speak for protesters around
the world they're speaking for
themselves
there's no reaction these protesters are
speaking for themselves
compare that response
with Biden's reaction to other protests
it's a wake-up call to our nation we
won't let those who see this as an
opportunity to sow chaos throw up a
smoke screen
to distract Us in very real religious
legitimate grievances
at the heart of these protests you can't
leave this moment thinking
that we can once again turn away and do
nothing
of course the George Floyd protests
do the protesters in China not have real
legitimate grievances
G is a vicious cruel murderous dictator
he's going to go down as one of the most
destructive people in the history of the
world
and if you had a chance to stand up to
him and you didn't take it because you
thought you could get more NBA
merchandise on the shelf or do some more
IPOs over there then that is shameful
or if you're a lawyer or you're a
lobbyist and you work for these people
because you want to pay your mortgage
that way or just your vacations then
it's just as bad blood money all of it
as long as she leads China it will
remain the single greatest threat to our
freedom and our stability we have to do
everything in our power right now to
decouple to bring home um U.S
manufacturing and stop funding their
military buildup and by the way also
their dangerous medical research which
still goes on
we don't want another American killed by
Chinese drugs we don't want another
American worker to lose his job or his
company to unfair Chinese Trade
Practices we don't want one more
American student to lose his or her slot
at one of our universities
this must end
there can be no equivocation or
apologizing as we defend our freedom our
independence and our way of life and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else